you
hi everyone is Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics training I'm gonna try three
more puzzles and just share my thoughts
along the way so let's try this first
one where I'm playing as white okay this
is interesting my first thought is that
this is a position out of the caro-kann
one where yeah one where there's the
advanced variation and there's a Bishop
b5 g6
something with the bishop coming back to
h7 and in an e6 pawn sack that's just a
little side note but um okay so this is
my first thought giving a check here hmm
oh I think I see it
this Knight is restricted to the defense
of the rook so we could give a check for
starters King here and then upon push
attacks the night if he moves we grab
the rook and if he doesn't move well we
capture the knight so Queen check King
here g5 if pawn takes now we have Knight
takes on g5 all sorts of threats the
main one at that point being Knight f7
which would be a fork on the king and
queen but on top of that there's Knight
takes rook and if the rook goes to h8 or
h6 it's still the same story Knight f7
is going to be very strong um let me see
for a second is there anything else I
don't think so I think it's just the
immediate check and then something to do
with this push Queen and Knight are the
only attacking pieces in this position I
don't think it's going to be anything
else
so Queen check just double-checking here
Queen check King to d8 g5 pawn takes
Knight takes and maybe they'll already
call it a puzzle let's go for it okay
that is the correct start and now g5
that's correct now Knight takes and
that's it nope we're going to play one
more out and it's this pretty sure
Knight f7 and it is at that point the
problem solved so I guess after king
here
well you could just take the rook first
you know you have you have your pick I
think there's multiple good moves at
that point but white is simply going to
be winning material all right let's try
that second one so that was interesting
a pretty realistic puzzle out of the
caro-kann advanced variation again with
E 5 Bishop f5 G for kicking the bishop
back if it does still say on this
diagonal there's this e 6 pawn advance
and from this puzzle it was a white
exploiting blacks light squares ok let's
try a puzzle to
team black hmm okay
two big race I guess these guys can
create a past pond
let's see I think I know the solution to
this one okay I'm pretty sure the first
move is you have to take the night
however no let's let's hold off for a
moment I think I see the solution
immediately but I'm just I'm going to
try this first my quick initial thought
is pon takes King takes king to e7
forcing King to g7 and then only pushing
the pawns forward to eventually promote
on a dark square which would give
checked the King on g7 but can you just
immediately run with the pawns no I
don't think I don't think that's the
direction in fact if white really wanted
to after a for this pawn could continue
to push and there won't be any pawn
promoting with check against the white
King black would promote first and then
white would promote right after but and
the knight couldn't track him down like
if a 599 to f4
then
you could probably do a three or B three
at that point I think you'll be pushing
through
I'm gonna go with pawn takes knight with
this following idea pawn takes knight
King takes pawn and then King to e7 pawn
takes knight King takes pawn king eise
'even if h5 then there's King to f8 h6
King to g8 the king will be there to
stop the pond so pawn takes knight King
takes pawn King e7 first and then King
to g7 his shoulder off the black king
from getting to f8 only at that point do
we start pushing at the pawns
a5 h5 b3
pawn takes pawn and not the immediate
recapture but rather a 3d got the goal
will be to promote so that we could give
check I think that's it alright
King here oh my goodness
really what am I missing
wow I really was not expecting that
what's wrong with King here pawn push
immediately really I'm actually quite
stunned that that is the solution to
push right away huh
what was wrong with my thought oh maybe
nothing maybe my way is still fine
because this pawn will be there in time
to stop this pawn from promoting
hmm I think both are fine this is I
guess more direct maybe I should have
seen it as this prior to forcing the
king to a dark square would there really
be anything wrong with King to e7 this
King cannot catch these pawns King e7 if
the King tries to go in this direction
he will not be fast enough because of a4
and then b3
similar idea with pawn takes there's
always a three and he's super fast huh
so King e7 h5 King f8 h6 King g8 I think
that would be another direction to go I
think that's also solution but it's just
apparently the immediate push with this
idea where you don't recapture but
instead address the idea of this pawn
promoting on H a and you could stop it
by promoting on the a1 square okay well
I guess I didn't get the exact solution
to this one but I think mine was still
good but let's try them let's try this
last one puzzle three of three there we
go okay hmm
all right there's a knight check in a
queen check multiple checks pawn push
is one night here is two three four five
although this one isn't going to be so
good so four checks probably not the
pawn push hmm my first thought is to get
the knight in the center post and then
depending on where the King goes you
could give a check from there let's see
though hmm Knight check where would the
King go from there also rook takes
Bishop check I don't know if you'd
really want to invite the Queen over to
defend some squares over here
if night check King here what's the
follow-up
hmm
oh no you know what the fur
movers okay the
first move his queen h7 keep in mind
there's also this bishop so so far I've
only been focusing on the Queen and the
knight doing stuff to the King but if
this King ever tries to run away to this
d7 square keep in mind there's Bishop H
h3 to control that queen h7 limits the
black King to two choices so let's
actually go with that first and fit in
fact if we went with the knight check he
has much many more options if 95 check
he has d8 f 8 GA and g7 and while even
he's six which probably isn't a good
idea but nevertheless he has many more
options than he would have after queen
h7 so queen age seven he has f8 and e 8
if King to e8 there's Queen g8 check the
bishop cannot block because it's in a
pin so Queen check King here the bishop
is paralyzed he's pinned he and so that
would force King to d7 and there's
Bishop here and the other variation
would be Queen h7 King f8 Queen aah
check our Queen to h8 check King f7
now
95 check
and we're going to soon have mate
because King e6 would be forced to then
comes Bishop to h3 that's game over
mmm this one wasn't so sophisticated I
guess let's try it that is the first
move Queen check here and then the
knight gets to enter the black position
with check and that's it it's going to
be mate on the next move King e6 is the
only move and that is met with fish of
h3 and that's game over all right those
weren't too bad I don't know what the
story was with the second one feel free
to share how you did with these three
problems and as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye my
first thought is believe it or not
Knight b6 because I'm seeing a way where
you could get to c4 with tempo and then
there's